the head of one of the naacp chapters
was just caught
on camera saying that if you are a
parent
who protests critical race theory in the
schools who protests the sort of
anti-american ideologies that are
tearing down our country
but you should just die
and remain steadfast steadfast in
speaking truth
tearing down double standards and the
beauty double talk
let's not allow any double downing on
lies
let's prepare our children for a world
they deserve let's deny this off-key
band of people
that are anti-education anti-teacher
anti-equity anti-history anti-racial
reckoning
and to help people into diversity
anti-platform
anti-science interchange agent
anti-social justice
anti-health care anti-worker anti-lgbtq
plus
anti-children anti-health care
anti-worker anti-environment
anti-admissions policy change
anti-inclusion
auntie live and let live people let them
die
don't let these uncomfortable people
deter us from our old
march forward let them die
so on the one hand this i think this is
a threat
because we have heard especially from
blm and antifa
and we've seen especially from blm and
antifa and other
leftist radical groups the use of
political violence the use of terrorism
the use of violence against civilians to
achieve
a political end we've seen that a lot
over the past year so i do think this is
a threat
but it's not just a threat it's actually
even more insidious than a threat
it is the explanation of what the left
means by progress it isn't a vowel of
belief
in progress with a capital p is what
what this woman is saying is
we radicals are going to win we are
going to transform this country we are
going to
fundamentally invert this country and
it's just going to happen
that's the arc of the moral universe
it's long but it bends toward justice
that's what progress is and so
if we just wait them out they will die
and that'll be a good thing and then we
can move on
now it's worth noting what she's saying
here because
sometimes you'll hear people on the
right talking about
replacement migration or this idea that
the traditional american demographic
makeup is going to be radically
transformed and this is part of a
political agenda
and that belief is called white
supremacist and
nazi and fascist and you know all the
things that they call every other thing
that uh
anyone to the right of hillary clinton
believes but what this woman is saying
is that right she she is
giving credence to that theory she's
saying yeah let them die whether it's
the evil straight white men whether it's
the terrible conservatives more broadly
you let them die they're going to die
out and they're going to be replaced
by good radicals of this wonderful new
coalition that we're putting together
you've there have been other prominent
leftists who have said this and then
even in the washington post and in other
major major
outlets of the legacy media you will see
them come out very often and say
ha ha this terrible straight white men
are about to
be supplanted as a big portion of the
population so they give credence to this
theory too
and i don't think that they would refer
to themselves as nazis and white
supremacists
and so forth but they believe that that
is part and parcel
of progress and and they're obviously
willing to engage in acts of violence to
do so
they not only say it in speeches like
this but they actually have committed it
during for instance the blm riots hey
stop i'm really glad
that you enjoyed all that terrible right
wing misinformation that i i just was
spreading
you know recklessly around the internet
if you want even more of that reckless
misinformation
go check out the full episode which is
available now on this channel it's also
available on apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play
all over the place at the michael
knowles show and you can also order
my book chock full of deplorable
terrible right wing
misinformation go get that too that's
speechless we'll see you next time
[Music]
you